hi my name is Serena and I'm going to
tell you about the difference between
the internet and the web as you know one
of the marvels of modern technology is
the internet something you probably use
every day
maybe all day you go on the internet or
you surf the web a lot of people use
these terms the Internet and the web
interchangeably but they actually mean
different things the Internet is the
network of machinery that allows access
to the web the web is just a collection
of pages that may have text or images on
them basically the web is a subset of
Internet traffic to visualize this you
can imagine a highway the physical
highway are the paths between the
computers on the Internet network the
moving vehicles are the packets of
information that travel through these
internet paths there are many types of
vehicles cars trucks and motorcycles
they correspond to the different types
of traffic on the Internet
the cars are analogous to the web
traffic the trucks are to the email
traffic and the motorcycles are to the
media traffic so as you can see there is
a difference between the Internet and
the web being that the Internet contains
the web but the web is not the Internet